thank you
my favorite tailgate food is barbecue
ribs because don't nobody do it like I
do it
[Music]
jambalaya jambalaya it's the perfect
dish you got rice you got meat it fills
you up and it has good stuff in it I
love Mac macaroni and cheese cheese it's
so cheesy it's definitely the mac and
cheese and I just like hanging out with
my family probably brisket pulled pork
anything barbecue I would say barbecue a
chips and dip I'm going with the
Chick-fil-A chicken minis that are on
their way I like those little turkey
rolls in the tortilla I appreciate pigs
in a blanket you know it's under
underestimated but they do the job and
here's a peanut butter sandwich banana I
just had one actually in my truck I'm a
big fan of Crawfish Boil because you
just throw it out on the table and
everyone has a good time the pork with
the sweet barbecue
[Music]
so today we actually have a Tex-Mex
theme with our tailgate we've got some
taquitos some cheese burritos a Tex-Mex
butterboard chips salsa guac cheese dip
sausage balls sopapillas homemade
cookies and a little bit of Arby's
thrown in for good measure
it's just an atmosphere unlike any other
there's so much variety when it comes to
tailgating
people do live music people will play a
lot of games so it's just a overall
really fun environment here
obnoxious
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the corner of Lumpkin array the
libation station by far the greatest
tailgate in America
I'm sure everybody stays hydrated it's
like Bobby Boucher you got to make sure
the water is disrupted been at this
since like 28 30 years we're all UGA
graduates and we just love to serve the
people we love the University of Georgia
and we love the dogs we're in the
tailgate of like the reservation station
I don't know how to pronounce it this is
the target I've been going to for a
couple years now and or basically my
whole life it's multi-generational kids
grandkids grandparents Everyone is
always welcome that's what makes it fun
too to connect
today we've got we've got about 120
pounds of London Broil that we cook we
got all kind of sides cream corn butter
beans beads we got all kinds of
phenomenal traditional southern food
here at tailgate food public sweet tea
and uh anything that guy puts on the
grill I need you to act like it's not
your last meal
[Music]